[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator TV
and broadcast on Thursday the 23rd of
February I'm Kate Andrews the
spectator's economics editor and your
host this week coming up on the show
as Britain promises to send more arms
out to Ukraine what's become of the
nation's hollowed-out army with the UK
be prepared to fight in a war on the
cheap I'll be speaking to Andrew Roberts
and the right honorable Tobias Elwood MP
negotiations over the Northern Ireland
protocol are in full swing with rumors
of a deal coming soon but can Rishi
sunak meet everybody's demands and who
will have to compromise Arlene Foster is
with me on the show
shamima begum has just lost her latest
appeal to return to the UK one Brit who
knows her better than most these days is
Andrew Drury an extreme Taurus who got
to know her over the course of a year he
joins me on the show
does religion have a place in politics
this week Kate Forbes has been in the
firing line over her personal beliefs
has she been the victim of a Witch Hunt
or does the public have a right to know
what she thinks on topics such as gay
marriage and having children outside of
marriage I'm joined by a member of her
church David Robertson
and finally meal deals are a much-loved
bargain in supermarkets but in Wales
there is talk of restriction I'll be
speaking to Lucy Dunn who eats meal
deals at least once maybe twice a day
before we get going if you enjoy
spectator TV then do subscribe to our
YouTube channel just click the Subscribe
button at the bottom of this video and
tap the Bell icon to make sure you never
miss an episode
and if you want to read more from The
Spectator then why not subscribe to the
magazine for just 12 pounds you can get
12 weeks in print and online and a free
20 pound Amazon voucher just go to
spectator.co.uk forward slash TV offer
to subscribe
the historian and author Andrew Roberts
takes a look at Britain's hollowed-out
armies for the cover piece in this
week's magazine as Rishi sunak promises
to send more Weaponry to Ukraine can
Britain afford to restock at the rate at
sending out arms once seen as one of the
strongest armies in Europe what's now
left of the nation's defense
to discuss Andrew Roberts joins me now
alongside MP Tobias Elwood
Angie thanks for joining spectator TV
for the cover piece this week you talk
about how Britain is fighting the second
Cold War on the cheap how vulnerable are
we uh we're much more vulnerable now
than we've been um I think in my
lifetime it's a very worrying moment uh
it's extraordinary that the Secretary of
State for defense Ben Wallace has
himself publicly said that the Army has
been hollowed out we've lost 30 billion
uh in real terms in defense spending
over the last uh years since the Tories
came in in 2010 and I'm speaking as a
Tory Pier you know I'm I'm uh not in any
way criticizing
um the government for this but it is
something that really does need to be
changed quickly Andrew critics will say
that we still have the strongest army in
Europe how would you respond to that
um well we do and we're not going to
have next year and certainly not by
three years time when we're going to
have the fifth largest at least by
defense spending the Germans and the
French are going to out uh spend us
within the next three years so it's all
very well for the government to say this
but you've got to look of course into
the future and you've also got to
remember that there is a land war going
on in Europe at the moment Tobias you
were PPS in the ministry of Defense
between 2017 to 2019 you sit on or chair
a host of committees related to defense
what are you seeing on the inside
I I see us I suppose in a step back
being rather complacent over the last 30
years I think we've become used to
perhaps you know some skirmishes some
problems in the Middle East but in
general since the end of the Cold War uh
I think we've become a little bit timid
a little bit risk-averse in standing up
to some of the challenges around the
world and I think they're now coming
back
to haunt us we've got uh geopolitical
shift in capability uh in military might
and agenda as well and I think this is
coming to manifest itself
in Ukraine I don't think Russia for
example would have invaded
um Ukraine had we not departed from
Afghanistan and I don't think that China
would be doing what it's doing in the
South China Sea and so forth if it
didn't feel that the West was so uh
collectively divided and unable to
perhaps challenge
um these larger countries from perhaps
exploiting the limitations of our
International rules-based order Tobias
do you think the government has
acknowledged the scale of the problem
when it comes to the UK's capacity to
defend itself and to defend other
countries
no not at all and I think perhaps that's
also a fault of myself and the
government as well and others perhaps
commentators in making the connection
between you know what goes on in my
constituency why is the uh the price of
bread gone up why is there a cost of
living crisis why is Energy prices gone
up and they are directly related uh to
some degree as to what's going on in
Ukraine in Security in Europe is a
direct consequence to what's going on
globalization as a whole has become much
much tougher as countries retreated not
just because of covid but also because
the general direction of travel of where
our as I say a fragile world is going as
security becomes more of a concern so
that justifies if you like spending more
on defense making sure that we have the
resilience we have the capability to
look after our supply chains and so
forth Britain Embrace globalization
arguably more so than other countries
and now we're recognizing the
limitations of that or how vulnerable uh
we are to you know changes fluctuations
or indeed challenges to our
accessibility to the world and I would
add to that that it's in concerts that
I'm sitting here with a historian but we
are uh perhaps in our DNA that as a
nation we step forward perhaps when
others hesitate to challenge
um the world uh when it does go awry and
I would love to see us rekindle that
capability we have convening power still
I think that soft power of being able to
identify some of the problems offer
Solutions not necessarily doing all the
heavy lifting but certainly offering
some of the the you know the way out the
direction of travel Ukraine perhaps is a
the first example where we've been
pushing the envelope more but at the
moment it's very very difficult for us
to then justify further defense spending
increases unless I say we translate it
into what goes on uh into the everyday
livelihoods because that will be
affected in the longer term it if we
don't you know boost our security and
our standing up defense posture now and
only about the Army itself are the armed
forces strong enough at the moment you
know it in your piece that 4 000 more
have just been deployed to Estonia
um yeah well they're about to be an
extra 4 000 but they're protected by six
heavy guns
um and we don't have very many more
heavy guns in this country at least not
ones that work we've given 30 of course
to the ukrainians and we were right to
do that that's a that's a good uh
expense but what we're not doing is
building any more to take their place at
the moment the treasury have not
provided the money to do that let alone
the shells we're down to about three
days worth of shells in this country if
they're expended on the same kind of
rate as the um
uh both the Russians and the ukrainians
expel expend them and this is very
worrying because
um it means that you can't essentially
deploy forces abroad unless you're able
to protect them and talk us through that
process of restocking Weaponry where is
it manufactured how long does it take
well British Aerospace does a lot
um there's a plant in Wales that that
does it actually it doesn't take that
long if you've got the money
um and the contracts that you can place
there is a discussion about how long
these shelves these shells have a shelf
life and that can be you don't want to
use you know shells that are coming up
to their uh their sell-by date as it
were but nonetheless we are now down as
I say to two or three days worth and you
can see from this war in Ukraine that is
now one year old that you need many more
than that and again you also have to
spend about 10 million pounds per heavy
gun if you want a 155 millimeter or a
105 millimeter you know it's that kind
of money and the treasury which has been
in complete control for the last hundred
years the power that it has over the mod
and all of the other big spending
departments is so centralized now that
you have to face the fact that the
treasury has a very strange way of
looking at defense firstly it assumes
that you can pretty much always cut
because we're not in a catastrophe and
secondly it has this um this approach
where because some monies have been
essentially wasted
um on on systems that haven't turned out
to work particularly well that therefore
they shouldn't be the mod shouldn't be
given money for things like guns and
shells which are pretty low-tech and
which we know do work very well to bias
this conversation keeps coming back to
money and their calls for the Prime
Minister and Chancellor to increase the
defense budget as early as the next
fiscal statement in March do you agree
with that call to increase the defense
budget
yes I mean I've been saying this for
some time now that we've now because of
where our world is going we need to move
ever closer to a war footing during the
last Cold War we spent up to about four
percent of GDP on defense uh and at the
moment we're at a peacetime level of
about just over two percent it's made
more complex because of Foreign Exchange
levels in inflation and so forth which
means that Ben Wallace the defense
secretary is simply asking for 10
billion more just to stay at this level
of capability and as you've just heard
there there is huge concerns about our
stockpiles huge concerns about our
supply chains as well all the components
that are made up in any complex weapon
system come from across uh the world and
some of them are obsolete star streak
for example is a very effective weapon
that we've gifted to the ukrainians we
actually stopped making this a couple of
years ago I visited the factory the
tallest Factory in in Belfast and
there's been no ask never request indeed
going back to the treasury to say let's
make Star Trek 2.0 to do that would cost
100 million just to get the supply chain
just to get the assembly line I guess
the really I guess the big question to
bias is is where is the money coming
from you say simply 10 billion but that
is no small chunk of change at the best
of times and money is in very short
supply these days
uh there's no doubt about it but I again
I go back to my original thesis that if
we don't look after ourselves and
provide the resilience and security for
the nation uh in alignment with our
allies as well I'm afraid the world's
changing very very fast indeed it's
becoming more dangerous so it won't just
be the mod's budget that will suffer our
economy as a whole will run into
difficulties we need to better recognize
and Germany has just done this for the
first time
since the second world war that economy
and security are one and the same thing
you cannot distinguish one from the
other we cannot isolate ourselves in the
UK and say come on let's focus on that
money for hospitals for schools and so
forth and uh and all these local
expenditure perfectly understand the
calls for that but if you drop your
interest uh in security then I'm afraid
there are you know countries out there
with very different agendas today that
will take advantage of our over-reliance
if you like uh on our International
Supply Chain we weren't sorry can I just
yeah please can I just uh add that we've
um found of course uh only today that
there's been a 5.4 billion Surplus in
tax revenues well that could go straight
into defense that would be half of what
Ben Wallace is asking for and what he
needs so it's not as though there is no
money and what we have to remember all
the time is that Putin is spending 143
billion uh dollars on which is 30
percent of uh of government income in
Russia on defense and security so you
know whatever we spend frankly is going
to be a tiny
um proportion of what he's spending and
this is a proper proxy war that is going
on in Europe but of course Andrew that
increased tax take has been offset by
near record high deficits that the UK
are still running and of course the
treasury feel as though they're still
trying to get their ducks in a row when
it comes to sorting the public finances
Tobias started to hint at it there you
know there's competition for money for
education for the NHS and for defense
what argument would you make to say that
defense now needs to be the priority the
fact that it's been traded off again and
again ever since well long before 2010
as Tobias said it's been 30 years
essentially that the um the defense has
been the poor man in this uh in this
battle when you look at the amounts that
are spent on well you mentioned health
and education which have spiraled again
and again you see uh defense being cut
and the reason that you need to do it is
not just because of these sort of
statements that all politicians make
about about defense being the first
priority of of government but actually
you cannot fight a war without heavy
artillery and we have got virtually no
guns left in this country and three-day
supplies of shells it should be a
massive National worry and a disgrace
and a scandal but it simply isn't
because we have seen the treasury slice
back the defense budget for as I say
three decades Tobias last question to
you following president zielinski's
visit to the UK there's been pressure on
the UK to supply fighter jets and tanks
to the front line is the UK in a
position to do that given its depleted
Army status
well it it actually opens up a whole
Pandora's box of questions there firstly
why did it take so long for us to gift
the the hardware the tanks themselves
which is exactly what zelinski have been
calling for
for some time if we want to see Ukraine
make progress it's going to have to
punch through that defensive line and
start to gain territory that's why the
tanks are needed but tanks require top
cover and in order to give them the the
advantage and that's where the fast Jets
come in I would have been asking for air
power rather than fast yet because
actually as we learn it takes about four
to five years to train a fast jet pilot
not so simple thing to do there are
other ways that you can provide that top
cover for the tanks using super Tucanos
a10s for example drone aircraft as well
if you have disguise if you're
dominating the skies already because
you've got great air defense you know
the Russians are not using their their
Air Force then you can use these uh uh
other variants uh of air power which are
not as good absolutely make that clear
and make it happen in conjunction while
you start training uh your Cadets your
uh in the western flight schools which
is what absolutely we need to do but all
this poses a bigger question as to what
we're doing this for what does Victory
look like and that's not been clarified
even a year after the invasion itself
and I think the West needs to come to
terms with the fact this isn't just
about Ukraine this is Russia having a go
at the West as a whole probably in
alignment and support with China in the
background providing the weapons
components that Russia needs to keep
this going this is much much bigger than
just Ukraine and the quicker we put the
fire out the Ukraine the quicker we can
reduce inflation down to about you know
four to five four to five percent which
will make it easier then pay for all
these other things that we've been
speaking about you get the grains coming
out of Odessa for example that will help
reduce the cost of living prices so
again it's in our interest to be less
hesitant less risk-averse stop being
spooked by Putin and start to help
Ukraine in the scale that they actually
require it Tobias and Andrew thanks for
joining me
brexit negotiations are back and it
could be whenever she see next greatest
challenges in his Premiership the Prime
Minister has the near impossible task of
meeting everyone's demands balancing the
red lines of the EU with protecting the
sovereignty of Northern Ireland a
complicated topic but with me now is
Arlene Foster former leader of the dep
who has seen it all before
Arlene thanks for joining spectator TV
we are back to talking about the brexit
negotiations and we've been here before
you know exactly what these talks are
like so what will be the main Crux of
the prime minister's talks with the dup
right now
well first of all I'm glad to hear he's
finally speaking to the dep and I
understand there have been numerous
contacts now
um although I don't think they've seen
any texts as such
um they're certainly been giving more of
where the negotiations because
fundamentally
um if the dep on behalf of their voters
and I think it's important to say that
because people talk about the dep as if
there's some freestanding organization
they have a mandate and they've been
voted into this position this is a
position they went to their electorate
with last year
therefore they have to be convinced that
it's the right thing to do and they've
set out their seven tests they did that
six months before they left the
executive nothing happened at all there
was no engagement and since then they've
been really waiting for Action whether
through the Northern Ireland protocol
bill or through negotiations so at least
now there seems to be progress being
made which is really good and I do hope
that there's a continued dialogue and
perhaps even sharing of negotiation
stances and texts because that's what's
needed we know about the dep's test but
can you be a bit more specific as to
what red lines cannot be crossed well I
don't think it's a question of red lines
because I think everybody wants to get
Devolution back and sometimes when I
read some of the commentators over here
and they say oh just go on without the
dup well what would be the point of that
because the whole issue is to get
Devolution back and to get the balance
back into the Belfast agreement again
because
people are talking about the Belfast
agreement and sometimes I don't think
they've actually read the Belfast
agreement Kitty because the whole idea
behind that is to have balance between
nationalism and unionism constitutional
position is that we're part of the
United Kingdom until such times as the
people of Northern Ireland decide
otherwise so that's a critical point and
then there has to be this balance in
terms of East-West and north south and
that's where it's really fallen down
under the protocol
you will eventually get a vote on the
protocol if it were to stay in place is
that something that the dep want to
avoid no it's not something they want to
avoid but even that vote
um it's quite technical but the
Secretary of State brought a piece of
legislation to Westminster to change the
mechanism for voting so instead of a
majority of nationalists and a majority
of unionists agreeing to what would
happen in relation to the protocol it's
now a majority vote and that goes
against the spirit of the Belfast
agreement and really what it was all
about so I really do think there's a
need to get that balance back into the
Belfast agreement it's now 25 years old
on the 10th of April so I think it is
important to recognize what it actually
says about balance and about making sure
that the both communities in Northern
Ireland are at peace with what is
happening there is perhaps no perfect
solution to the problems that it is
with the protocol yeah where can the
compromise be found where is the dep
going to be more willing to compromise
well you see I think
when you look at what happened with the
protocol there was a fun if you go back
to 2017 and I'm sorry we have to go back
to the trees we're all going back we're
all getting triggered by the memory yes
I'm having flashbacks so that's any
constellation
um but if you go back to 2017 there was
a fundamental misunderstanding of the
Belfast agreement so I think the first
thing that needs to be done is that
there is an understanding of what the
agreement actually says about our
constitutional position within the
United Kingdom and indeed about the fact
that there needs to be this balance
between the communities in Northern
Ireland I think that the European Union
has either been misled or misunderstood
what's in the Belfast agreement so
really what needs to happen is that
there's an understanding of that and
once there's an understanding of that I
think we can deal with the trading
issues through some of the things that
were talked about at that time you will
remember them alternative Arrangements
small business exemptions trusted
Traders is something that I've seen
mentioned again for the first time in in
years
so there's a numerous ways we can deal
with the trading issues because of
course the amount of trade that goes
across from Northern Ireland into the
single European market is very very
small when you look at the proportion
compared to the rest of the single
European market but in terms of the GB
to Northern Ireland Market that's our
main Market that's where most of our
Goods circulate within the UK internal
market and therefore that needs to be
remedied well it's interesting that
these old terms are coming up because
from memory the dep was not very happy
about what Boris Johnson negotiated in
2019 that essentially puts a trade
border between Great Britain and
Northern Ireland so are you happy that
Rishi c-neck has returned to the table
and reopened those negotiations oh well
absolutely we want them to reopen those
negotiations and more than that the
protocol itself foresees a reopening of
the negotiations I spoke to David Jones
the deputy chair of the ERG last week
and he said he voted for the withdrawal
agreement including the protocol because
he always believed the protocol was
temporary and that is a theme that keeps
running now and actually it was
confirmed in court that it was seen as
temporary so if it's a temporary piece
then surely it can be renegotiated and
something different can be put in its
place Arlene I'm curious to know what
Northern Ireland is like at the moment
there have been reports that it's
difficult for residents to get the goods
and the trade that they normally like to
have over from Great Britain what are
the communities feeling well you see
this is the point when we the outworking
of the protocol has actually shown to
people in Northern Ireland they are
being treated differently than people in
Great Britain and they find that very
difficult because they are UK citizens
as well as the people in Great Britain
some feel as if they're second-class
citizens actually they can't get their
goods across from various places where
they would have went online ordered
stuff from now they're being told sorry
we don't deliver to Northern Ireland and
the reason why they don't virgin
Northern Ireland is it it's too much
hassle and it's too costly that can't be
right surely if the UK single Market is
to mean anything it means that everybody
can access Goods within the market and
have them delivered to their homes so
people are angry about that on the other
hand and to be fair you will find that
there are some companies who manufacture
who want to continue to do business with
the European Union and for them they are
saying can we not have dual Market
access in other words within the single
Market of the United Kingdom but also
have access into the European Union and
the way to do that as was pointed out by
the David Trimble at the time of course
the architect of the Belfast agreement
is to have dual Market recognition in
other words if there is a change in the
regulations for the EU or for the UK
that you would have that dual Market
recognition within Northern Ireland and
I think that's a really good way forward
but we haven't heard anything around
that in these negotiations Mutual
recognition was a big point a big
talking point for many brexiteers but it
always seemed like the EU was hesitant
on that point and from their perspective
they didn't want to dilute their single
Market status does it feel like anything
shifted from those perspectives no I I
have to say I don't feel there has been
a great shift in relation to that if
there if there was a recognition by the
European Union that they did value the
Belfast agreement and they did want to
see Northern Ireland move on and have
Devolution back and I think that that is
one of the ways in which they could
really stretch themselves and do that
because as I've said the leakage into
the European single Market is so small
when you compare it with the overall
trading that it wouldn't do any damage
to the single Market at all
uh you've worked with two prime
ministers on brexit negotiations Theresa
May and Boris Johnson you have an arms
length now from these negotiations but
you know from the inside and the outside
I suppose what do you make of Rishi next
negotiating tactics
well I was very concerned uh about the
fact that he was
um
seemingly conducting these negotiations
without actually speaking to the dup or
indeed the other parties in Northern
Ireland last Friday he came across he
gave them I understand a sense of where
the negotiations were at but if we are
to move forward and to get the dup to
sign up to this deal and believe you me
that's what I want to see happening
because I want to see Northern Ireland
with its own Devolution and with things
working normally within the United
Kingdom
um if he is to do that then he must
really get alongside them and understand
what they want it's not just looking at
words on a page in relation to their
seven tests but to have those
conversations with the leadership of the
dep
I think there's been more engagement
this week but I don't think it's been as
much as what is needed and I do hope
that he realizes that if he is to make
this a success because it would be a
huge success for him as well let's not
forget that if he is to make it a
success then he does really need to get
alongside the dup leadership how much of
it can down to trust because it
certainly felt like perhaps some was
lost between the conservative party and
the dup oh I think that's right after
after the protocol went ahead in 2019
how much needs to be rebuilt well I
think that's absolutely right and then
of course there are some uh here
particularly in London who see the dup
as an odd Bunch who they can't really
understand perhaps that's because they
haven't taken the time to understand
them and that all flows for the
confidence and Supply agreement as well
when the dup which I was leading at the
time a female Anglican that has to be
said but yet I was caricatured in a very
particular way so there is a need for
more understanding as to what the dep
wants for the people of Northern Ireland
as British citizens living in Northern
Ireland and I think if people took the
time they would find that there is a
willingness to form the evolution again
they want to have the evolution again
they've always been a demolitionist
party and to do that however they need
to have the text in the proper way so
that we're protecting the citizens of
Northern Ireland as members of the
United Kingdom and Arlene I want to move
away from brexit and the politics of it
for just a moment and ask you about this
terrible shooting of a detective Chief
Inspector three men have now been
arrested for an attempted murder well
this is a an absolutely awful incident
because we have a police officer quite a
senior police officer of Judy with his
son at football training in his local
area he's putting the balls into the
back of the car after training and two
gunmen come up and start shooting at him
he falls to the ground and they continue
to shoot at him so he is in a very
critical position still I obviously said
my prayers to him and his family and
indeed to the clinicians who are are
looking after him at this present moment
in time but again
it is showing that in regards to
policing and the police in families they
do have to continue to be vigilant
because there are dissident Republican
terrorists out there who will use any
opportunity to disrupt Northern Ireland
and this is a murder attempt on a police
officer's life in front of his own child
so I think it's incredibly callous I'm
not young boy will take a lot of time if
ever to get over watching his father
been shot in that way the police at the
moment are reporting that the new Ira is
the primary focus of their investigation
and as that investigation goes on I'm
sure we will be updating you for now
Arlene thanks so much for joining
spectator TV thank you
if you enjoy spectator TV why not
subscribe to the magazine you can get 12
weeks of The Spectator in print and
online for just 12 pounds on top of that
we'll give you a 20 pound Amazon gift
voucher for free go to spectator.co.uk
forward slash TV offer
what kind of person is shamima begum the
Isis bride who recently lost her appeal
to return to the UK has divided public
opinion over the past few years Andrew
jury is into extreme tourism and has
visited some of the most dangerous parts
of the world just how dangerous does he
think begum is Andrew joins me now
Andy thanks for joining spectator TV
you've written for the magazine this
week about the friendship you say that
you've built up with shamima begum how
did this come about I think friendship
was uh past tense now because my latest
stuff was probably upset her quite a bit
um it come about I was filming a
documentary called danger zone which
followed me in My Strange Life of
holidays and danger zones so as a day
off from filming we were close to the
roach Camp which means kept
and I thought because there was a lot of
journalists have been thrown out so
because she said no to everybody so I
thought it was a bit of a challenge so I
wanted to go and see her and no it was a
good story the production company
weren't interested in her at all so went
into the camp but you personally wanted
to meet her yeah of course she's a big
story at home
um I can remember the pictures of seeing
her come through the airport with her
other two friends and yeah of course it
was a big story so I went into the camp
expecting to get told to go away but um
I had a pre-plan
um I was in a Netflix documentary where
I was in an orphanage and it was quite a
tear-jerking scene so I thought it might
be a good idea to show that and show my
softer side
um I showed but I showed her it she she
kind of got bought into it I think she
could realize I wasn't on his Hardline
newspaper journalists so she saw me as
somebody was a bit different than she'd
had seen before and she accepted me
um and the interview which I had with
her wasn't the Gen about the heads and
the bins the suicide Fest it was
generally about her about you know what
she used to do in her life when she was
younger what was her interest and she
bought into it and then she liked me
and as I the bit I still regret now as I
went to leave us a kind of shake hands I
didn't want to offend her because she
was a Muslim
um all for my hand she said I can have a
hug
um she gave me a hug and she started to
cry I'd never seen emotion before I
don't know now whether that was
orchestrated by herself as it went along
but that made some sort of bond I got a
daughter her age so I didn't see her at
that point as a Terrace I saw as a
victim
um in my mind she was groomed and at
that point and kind of that was about it
I never expected to ever see her again
and I left but how wrong I was I want to
go into that full story but first I
think a lot of viewers will be wondering
what exactly an extreme holiday is
because this was certainly not the first
or last time you went on one what does
that entail
Intel's being pretty stupid and going
places where everybody advises you not
to go the government advised not to go
though I generally went there right so
it's taken me from to chechnya it's
taken me Ku Klux Klan
um Frontline battle
um in kirkuk I've been taken hostage
only for a day and they bought me a
kebab well that makes it okay and then
rescuing a bear recently in war-torn
Ukraine so that's not your general
holiday and are you an adrenaline junkie
is that what you're seeking
it wasn't it was until the media took
over yeah I liked the adrenaline like
the buzz and I also like to tell
people's story when you come back I
always enjoyed relaying somebody's story
right through myself then I had the
medium of newspapers to do that and I
enjoyed I just enjoy that
um well uh this extreme holiday took you
to shimima and you visited her many
times at the refugee camp afterwards
what is it like in this prison camp what
are the conditions like compared to a
refugee camp which I've been through in
raqqa before
it's not bad I don't think it's it's a
Concrete in the middle of a concrete
bases with tents with kind of un plastic
sheeting made into a tent form shamim
has got a TV in a room she's got a fan
of air conditioning I don't know where
she's getting the money but and she has
and she's quite well dressed but it's a
Dusty dirty Place they've got a shopping
area where they can go and buy our
clothes and baby because a lot of
children in there as well as the baby
food Foods so they have money they I
don't know how they earn it because she
never told me at the prison camp is
splint too so you've got the real
extreme upper top end of the camp which
they don't think they could be
deregulized they're up there because
they're and they don't really mix with
the more Western girls
um which are on the other side which is
supposed to be a little bit easier
and you said at the start of our
interview that you think you were wrong
in terms of your first impression of
shamima what changed during your visit
um well on my second visit
um she told I knew that she could have a
phone call home she was entitled to one
phone call one week
um and I thought that'd be from the
office there's an Administration office
in there but she said they got mobile
phones in the camp so I gave her my
mobile number expecting a phone call but
I got text messages regular and one of
those text messages changed everything
about her I mean I had a brother died of
cancer young so I always kept that with
me and it never left me and when I was
there on my second visit in her purse
she has these two pictures and the third
one for charging her children the oldest
child I think was about eight months
when he died a chocolate man's face and
it was like a happy scene of cake making
um and I was quite upset by it because a
child obviously an innocent child had
died and it was eight months old so I
text sent a message to her a text
message and said I was really sad when I
saw that photograph of your your little
one and that her response shot me she
said oh don't worry I'm over that part
of my life it doesn't make me sad
anymore
and that I still can't understand I'd
say living with death myself of a young
child I just couldn't fathom how she
could be that way and how it seemed so
cold
it seems extremely cold I can't fathom
it either that said we have not grown up
in an Isis Community we haven't had the
experiences she had do you think perhaps
this was her way of deflecting what is
overwhelming and inconsolable pain
people always mention the trauma of what
she went for according to her in a
documentary never went for anybody she
was stuck in a room for seven months
didn't do anything stayed in and had no
trauma it was only during the bombing at
the end when bagoos actually got taken
out by the Western Alliance that she
actually had any trauma according to her
so I know I don't agree with that I
still think he'd hold the emotions I
mean if you were in a traumatic
situation your children got killed I
don't I don't agree with that at all do
you still see her as a victim on any
level
um
trafficking or a victim of grooming I
asked her and she ironically I watched
the documentary again stop trying to
refer back to that but she said that she
had trouble fitting in our society she
um racially she shared racing racist
abuse and racially she finds difficult
um to fit into a community well she
lived in a Bangladeshi community so that
would have been untrue and the question
about racism she she I asked her about
that and she said she'd only had one
small racist comment when she was in
infant School
was quite shocked so I don't think she
was groomed and then we've seen a video
and that video shown of the the park
everybody knows about the Isis video
propaganda video where you see this
beautiful scene this park and they've
got a Catherine wheel bumper cars and
they're walking around with candy floss
and now if that was the one video that
she watched
um to The Grooming video it's not true
I want to talk about the screaming point
a bit more because I think one of the
most startling points of of your article
for The Spectator is you say I spent
with the time you spent with her quote I
also went from thinking that she had
been groomed to thinking she was trying
to groom me yeah how do you understand
the definition of grooming in that
scenario it's a difficult one isn't it
it's changing somebody's beliefs and I
think at all persuasion and I think she
was doing that with me I think
I think she was trying
um trying to work me I suppose I mean
her side would be work by ISIS to um to
change her opinion to say that she was
going to go to a utopic situation
um I suppose grooming was with me was
conditioned me to her belief conditioned
me towards how she was I think critics
however would say that somebody in your
position with a family stability the
ability to travel is not a heart
Contender to be groomed where she
um you know despite the horrible things
that she owns up to doing and you know
needs to be accountable for was
ultimately a child and under UK law
would have been a victim of that lease
rape
um I think that's 15 year olds always
been used so many times it's you could
say that about a child that kills I mean
is everybody innocent at the age of 15 I
don't think so she could still have the
thoughts
um I think she went on her own free will
I don't think she was coaxed another
girl called because most people there
was only three girls that was four a
girl that went before
um shamina shamina went before and I
think it was just a conversation I I
don't think she did realize how extreme
it would be I would say that for sure
but she still had an anti-british
anti-west feeling do you think perhaps
she saw you as somebody who could help
her get back to the UK and when she
realized that you couldn't or wouldn't
that's when her attitude towards you
changed no her attitude changed to all
me when I wrote a newspaper article in
the paper that she didn't like right so
I wrote an article came back and said
that she could face trial and do 20
years in prison the newspaper article I
won't say the newspaper if you want me
to stated that she could be hung I never
said that so once again the paper wrote
the article wrong and which I got them
to apologize for and they apologized to
the SDF but however it was wrong and I
said shameema sorry the article was
wrong it wasn't what I wrote and I sent
her the actual transcript of the right
article but she come back and said it
doesn't matter about the article don't
care what article it was it's who what
paper you put it in my response to Algos
well you sold your country out you worry
about where I sold a newspaper article
and that was the last I heard of her you
say in the piece that you quote never
had an agenda when you met shamima no
you did help other journalists with
their interviews to interview me and
other Isis Brides where you paid for the
support that you gave the journalists
received a penny from any work I've done
for shameema at all
but do you where were you paid for
helping other journalists get in touch
with other Isis Brides when you were in
the area made any money at all for
anything I've done within that prison
camp do you think her perception of you
might have also changed when she saw you
were working with other journalists no
she actually liked it I mean the um Good
Morning Britain live interview she apart
from having a tantrum halfway through it
um she seemed to like it now it took
others after that and she liked that it
was simply because I think she had a
documentary made about her and I think
she might be manipulated by that
journalist not to speak to anybody else
shamima has just lost her appeal to
return to the UK what do you make of
that decision have the courts made the
right call
um no I don't
um I don't think you should be if you
were born in this country I don't think
you should be able to take somebody's
citizenship away from them I don't think
you can you're British you're born
British it doesn't matter what
generation of British your parents are
you're born in this country and I don't
think it's right I think she should come
back face trial here for our crimes I
think we have enough evidence or they
have enough evidence and I think that's
what should happen she should come here
and serve prison sentence here
feeling about her because I know her so
well last time she had a
um an appeal turned down in the high
court she was suicidal you were there at
the time weren't you with her I spoke to
her within hours or within days of that
being turned down she told me how
suicidal she felt and how flat she felt
and as a human being see it's a mixed
emotions because when you actually
I I don't hate her but I just don't like
what she stood for and I don't like the
way that she's gone but however
as a person I don't want someone in the
camp a young girl to be sitting worried
about you know or contemplating and
committing suicide because I feel
terribly guilty if I was part of
anything to do with that
does shamima have any more options and
trying to come to the UK she
um her options are well she's got the
core human rights so Elizabeth said
they're going to appeal they can appeal
against the Seattle Court's decision but
ultimately even if she gets a
citizenship some way
back then I would suggest that they'll
probably try her in Syria I don't think
the government are allowed to come here
because if you can imagine a government
that repatriates so it'd be a real
uncomfortable situation there's such a
um I think such a
adverse feeling towards shamim I don't
think it would be a good thing for any
government to bring it back so I think
it's a possibility she could go to trial
and Syria for about 20 years
I think she could get that
Andy thanks for joining me
Kate Forbes recently the front runner
for the SNP leadership race has
plummeted in the polls after a tough
week facing questions about her
religious views a devout member of the
Free Church of Scotland Forbes
personally believes that having children
out of wedlock is wrong as is gay
marriage but should it matter with
someone in politics thinks in their
private life David Robertson who is also
part of the Free Church writes for The
Spectators website this week and he
joins me now
David thanks for joining spectator TV
tell us about the Free Church of
Scotland which has been in the news this
week as of the past few weeks a lot of
people didn't really know about it yeah
there are people who would know a kind
of caricature where we're nicknamed the
we threes and the ideas that you know
we're a bunch of do are miserable
Scottish Calvinists who live on the
island speak Gaelic and never do
anything on a Sunday the caricature is
the only time the Free Church would get
in the news is if we announced that our
policy on the nuclear bomb was we didn't
want them to drop it on a Sunday so
there's a caricature thing of that but
in the 21st century the Free Church
somewhat surprisingly has grown and uh I
would say it's a conservative
theologically but not conservative
politically you can't confuse those two
things
um it a group of about a hundred
churches about 13 000 attenders
growing in the cities declining in some
other areas
but uh
yeah it's it's a bible-believing
conservative theologically Presbyterian
church and we break that down we now
know that Cape Forbes the SMP candidate
for first minister is a part of it and
you've repeated this phrase
theologically conservative what exactly
does that mean
it means that we accept the Bible for
what it is now people say do you mean
literally well it it literally depends
what they mean by literally so when
Jesus says I'm a door he doesn't mean
he's wooden and got a handle but what we
mean is that we we believe every word of
the Bible is true that we read it in
context in the different genres but we
think it applies to today so we're very
uh very much a bible-based church
um some people want to use the
pejorative fundamentalist I don't agree
I I think all of us have fundamental
beliefs anyway we think that we need to
apply the Bible to Modern Life
um what we don't think we have the
Liberty to do is to pick and choose
which bits of the Bible we like um I
think it was Saint Augustine who said if
you believe in the Bible what you like
and leave out what you don't like it's
not the Bible you believe but yourself
so
um I I think that there are people who
like to mock us as being somewhat
ignorant
um
I think one of the problems in the UK is
we are so influenced by American Media
that when people hear the word bible
believing or something they tend to
think of Southern redneck Evangelical
which I think is a bit unfair on the
southern uh people as well but it's a
caricature and so they
they tend to think of that except in
Scottish terms you've written a piece
for our coffee house on the spectator's
website and in that piece you mentioned
that whomso Yusuf hasn't been taken to
task about his faith but he was asked on
BBC Radio 4 whether he thinks gay
marriage and gay sex are wrong so why do
you think that this issue is specific to
Christians
oh I don't think it is I think it's Ian
McWhorter who's an atheist the Scottish
journalist brilliant writer who said
basically whomza Yusuf and Cape Fords
both belong to religions that condemn
homosexuality and gay marriage or
homosexual practice at least in
Christianity and gay marriage and uh the
the difference said my water is that one
of them's a hypocrite and one of them is
a Believer
um I I think that what was done with
Keith Forbes was an absolute Hatchet job
everybody knew what she believed and
it's utterly irrelevant I mean here we
are today Hamza Yusuf has just had a
report about the National Health Service
in Scotland which is devastating about
his management people are dying because
of that and that's not what people are
interested in they're interested in a
hypothetical of Kate Forbes who was 20
at the time when the same-sex marriage
stuff went through the Scottish
Parliament how she would have voted
there is no possibility of the Scottish
Parliament voting on same-sex marriage
in the next two parliaments at least
so I mean this is very much a handy job
and I think this is really unfair people
are having a go at Cape Forbes for
something holding a position that to be
honest a third of people in the UK still
hold and that was the normal position in
society up until about five minutes ago
hamsa Youssef has been challenged on
specifics in the Quran and he has
suggested that his Progressive beliefs
he feels can gel with his religious
beliefs
Forbes has been asked as you say about
how she would have voted on gay marriage
when she was a very young woman but is
the bigger question here not how she
would have voted on gay marriage but
what's going to happen when other social
issues come up in Hollywood because
whilst you say in your peace that Kate
Forbes has said that her beliefs would
not change how she votes she is hinted
quite strongly that had she had that
vote back in the day it would have
affected her vote and perhaps the
question for Scottish voters is what
else might come up I mean the trans
issue is still very much on the table in
Scotland with which she would use her
personal religious leanings to legislate
that to me is the ultimate question for
every candidate
well the ultimate question actually it's
not just personal religious beliefs
everyone has philosophical religious
beliefs everyone
so the the question is to what extent do
your personal beliefs affect things now
you mentioned the grr that's a that's a
great one um two-thirds of Scottish
people actually agree with cape Forbes
on this
isn't it ironic that we live I mean I
find this almost laughable that we live
in a world in which when a candidate is
asked what is a transgender woman say
the transgender woman is a biological
man
who wants to live as a woman
and she has been reported to the NEC of
the SMP for hate speech
and what's interesting about that is
humza Yusuf is the man who passed the
hate speech laws in Scotland
which would mean that in theory she
could go to jail for actually saying
something that is biologically
scientifically and rationally true so I
actually don't agree that when someone
says my beliefs won't affect how I vote
of course they will Kate Forbes
passionate passionately believes because
of her time in India where her parents
were serving in a charity for the poor
that she needs to do the best she can to
help the poor she passionately believes
that she passionately believes in
justice so I I think it's very foolish
to say you wouldn't allow your beliefs
to affect they certainly do I'm I have
to say I'm not sure at all what holmesa
believes to pick up on that point then
isn't the question for Scottish voters
because she is being very honest and
very clear about what she believes what
the trade-offs are for them because as
you say the majority of Scottish voters
happen to agree with Kate Forbes on the
trans issue plenty of them will agree
with her on the independence issue and
lots of other issues I'm sure there are
a lot of people out there who will be
nervous about the concept of hate speech
and and what can and cannot be said that
could potentially land you in prison and
certainly the way it's being interpreted
today but lots of people will disagree
with her about the rights for gay people
to get married or her comments about
having children outside of marriage and
they're weighing up which side they're
more comfortable with I mean there are
trade-offs here and that's something
that if you know in your own words Kate
Forbes is going to use her own beliefs
as she if she were to become first
ministers and don't the Scottish people
have the right to then weigh that up and
say well I agree with this I disagree
with this and you know they might decide
that the disagreements outweigh the
agreements
I I agree completely and I think the
Scottish people should decide that who
should not decide that is the twitterity
and I'm sorry to say this but
journalists so right now what I'm
hearing from people so I know that uh a
couple of days ago thousands of messages
of support were pouring in for Kate
Forbes
um I know that Nicholas sturgeon has got
involved today because she's really
shocked that that Kate Forbes has not
banked not banged down I would suggest
to you that um this is almost like a
Jacob Reed smog moment do you remember
that time when Jacob Reese morgue was
asked on I think it was on ITV good
morning what do you think about abortion
and he said well I'm against it and you
could almost see the journalists
salivating I've got him he's dead you
know and at the end of that I remember
that um
the guardian I think the next day ran a
headline which ineffectively said Jacob
Reese smog finished
well in the in the Westminster bubble
and in the Hollywood bubble that's true
but in the world of real people he
wasn't and I know Penn plenty people his
popularity soared in the following weeks
because there were plenty of people who
said I don't agree with him but oh my
goodness thank God for an honest
politician and I think Kate Forbes the
irony here is we have
people asking about a policy and
politicians should be judged on their
policy if you're going to judge people
on their character again with all due
respect Boris Johnson would never get in
you know and I think most politicians
we've had a bizarre situation in
Scotland here where experts have been
saying if only she lied
done what Tim Farren did which Tim
fahren now bitterly regrets which was a
very foolish thing I think the people
who are at fault here are the people who
are constantly asking her about gay sex
and same-sex marriage none of which is
relevant to the policies that the
Scottish government will be dealing with
over the next few years
the business Community love her if you
ask the business Community who they want
the Tories by the way I'll tell you this
I know this from speaking to many Tories
Tory leaders they kind of like cape
Forbes but they're desperate that she
doesn't get elected because if she gets
elected the Tories are finished in
Scotland
because she will win a lot of Tory votes
I guess my last question to you is that
perhaps the difference between Jacob
reesemark and Kate Forbes is that Jacob
Reese Mark has never put himself forward
for the top job and by doing that
naturally it comes with all kinds of new
scrutiny and as you say it's for the
people of Scotland to decide for the s p
to decide who they want to lead the
country but if they are curious about
the answers to her questions about for
example what she thinks of having a
child outside of marriage is it not
right that she's asked the question so
they at least get their answer and can
make an informed decision
no because that's not the basis on which
normal people make their decisions
very quickly very quickly it might be
when it comes to how would she legislate
for welfare how would she treat single
parent families what is the s p going to
do for these people are these not
legitimate questions to know what she
thinks from first principles
absolutely but that's not what they're
doing you see when that question is
being asked it's been asked us I got
your question Cape forms more than
anyone else in the s p leadership is
talking about poverty and everything
else that's her concern when she's asked
what is best for a child she says well I
think it's best for a child to grow up
with a mother and father virtually every
study agrees with that now the the
degradation of the family is what is
devastated Scotland I used to work in
housing Estates in Dundee and you know I
do kids camps in 19 out of the 20 kids
you couldn't say to them go home to your
mum and dad they were growing up
fatherless or they were going now that
that is to say that something is the
best is not to denigrate single mothers
and I think it's slanderous to imply
that because Kate Forbes thinks his best
for a child to grow up with two parents
that she's attacking single parents I
don't think that's true at all I think
she will do more welfare for the PO I
mean the SNP have been a disaster for
the poor in Scotland and I know because
my city was Dundee but she is in the SMP
I mean the the part of your criticizing
is also and the party that Kate Forbes
is representing
yes absolutely and and believe you me I
although Kate Forbes is a member of my
church if she was if she I think the
last chance for the SNP by the way is
Kate Forbes the s p want to commit
suicide they will and they'll do it
because of religion but not because of
Christianity because of the green
Progressive religion which has taken
over people's minds here we had a first
minister of Scotland who when asked if a
rapist was a a man or a woman who could
not answer
now I'm sorry that made us the laughing
stock of the world I'm here in Australia
and and people were just thinking is
this a Monty Python skit because it was
so ridiculous so I think Cape Forbes
people may not like her social views a
lot of people do but I think it's deeply
unfair that she's being condemned for
her social views when other people's
social views are not being discussed and
I think it's even worse that the real
policies are not being discussed so she
should be challenged on how you're going
to pay for Independence and so should
all the other the candidates I'm a
support of independence by the way so
I'll confess to that but I still think
that they've never answered that they
need to be challenged on the NHS they
need to be challenged on education
Scotland has the worst drugs deaths in
Europe if not the world and that needs
to be challenged on that by the way you
said something very very interesting I
need to need to deal with this you said
going to the top job I'm a Democrat
um and to be honest I'm pretty well a
republican as well and I'm far more
left-wing than most of these so-called
progressives who are not Progressive at
all they're a bunch of rich kids who've
been indoctrinated with some stuff from
Harvard and Yale and Oxford and
Cambridge and think it's wonderful and
think they can keep their millions and
then say that they're billionaire
socialists or something I'm not like
that I think that we should have a
proper democracy I don't care if Kate
Forbes is an MP a leader a finance
minister or or you know the first
minister to me in Scotland and I think
in the UK we we don't have a
presidential system I I don't want
somebody who you go oh that's our great
leader
um I think Nicholas sturgeon governed
like that and I think it's been a
disaster she has left my country
absolutely devastated I think Cape
Forbes has a slight possibility of being
able to rebuild it precisely because of
our Christian values hey Forbes
interviewed recently and I saw her five
questions on sex
you know what nerve I mean people go oh
you Christians are all obsessed by sex
we're not obsessed by it
it's the media they're obsessed by sex
nothing about industry nothing about
farming nothing about education nothing
about the NHS and I know what the people
of Scotland care more about and it's
certainly not Progressive issues that
seem to
this bubble that people seem to live in
that they're not the issues that we're
concerned about David thanks for joining
me
and finally this week the Welsh
government declared a war on meal deals
as part of its latest drive to tackle
obesity the three pound 50 on-the-go
lunch may be restricted a self-confessed
meal deal addict and The Spectator
social media editor Lucy Dunn is with me
now to defend them
Lucy thanks for joining spectator TV so
you write for the magazine this week
that Wales is eyeing the meal deal as
its next Nanny State Crackdown and this
is a particularly emotive issue for you
yes as I mean for as long as I can
remember I have eaten meal deals for at
least one if not two meals a day
um obviously this does come with breaks
if I go out for dinner but it's
important that you had to copy off yeah
but generally speaking in the day-to-day
routine you are hitting those meal deals
at least once a day absolutely
um usually test School tends to be the
one that I go for sometimes Sainsbury's
if um there's not Tesco around but I
have found out the best places to go and
for me the best combinations obviously
I'm going to want to hear all about
those as are our viewers but first I
want to know how you got into this meal
deal routine uh was it born of some kind
of necessity to your schedule because of
course you were practicing as a junior
doctor before you joined the spectator
yet when I was studying medicine I had
loads of exams and I didn't like to take
breaks in the library very often so when
I did I jumped to Tesco and as I say buy
myself a sandwich a snack and a drink
and it would be consumed with about five
minutes and that's me back to the
library again and as a student as well
that price point is pretty good you you
talk in the magazine piece about the
different price points they can range up
to a Fiverr absolutely I mean I would
always stick to around about the three
pound fifty Mark right you think that's
the best deal of the meal deals I think
so I think so I mean no I mean the Tesco
have upped their price considerably so
I'm tempted to move away from them
um but equally I think at the time I
thought three pounds 50 for a lunch deal
is actually pretty decent given the
other places if you go out for lunch
could be up to 10 pounds if not more
inflation is hitting everything so talk
me through the best meal deals I mean
obviously I've had a meal deal in my day
most people have but I can't say that I
have studied them and gotten to know the
meal deal quite as well as you have so
talk me through the best options
um well for me I am not particularly
fast whether it's cold food or hot foods
so and I often just go for uh chicken
Caesar salad wrap sometimes I go for a
salmon and cream cheese
um sandwich as well those kind of things
really appeal to me and sometimes a pack
of fruit on the side sometimes the
yogurt sometimes pack of crisps it's
like you can really mix it up yeah so
that's the beautiful thing you'll do I
think you can just literally every
single time you go you don't need to
have the same thing okay but um was it
always this way and you talk about the
history of the meal deal in your piece
and I'm not asking you to go back many
many years you know you wouldn't have
experienced that
um but talk a little bit about its rise
and then is it a recent thing that
they've offered so many options
so the meal deal was pioneered by boots
funnily enough in 1985 so not a
supermarket not a supermarket and yeah a
pharmacy so you know that's quite
surprising
um but it took off amazingly and I think
people found that the convenience aspect
of it really appealed to them after that
it expanded m s and Tesco's I say
Sainsbury's no waitrose have one as well
and with the expansion to different
supermarkets came all the different
items you can get you can now buy pasta
as a domain or a sushi
um so yeah I think the choice is
fantastic and you talk a little bit
about how they're even appealing to
breakfast yeah I mean this is the thing
so we've got sandwiches that offer egg
and bacon avocado and if you think about
what you'd have on a field English
breakfast it's not that December only it
was put between two slices of bread so I
I mean look you've sold the meal deal
really really well but it you know if
you were to do an even bigger pitch here
to be having it once or twice a day is
obviously a real commitment to the meal
deal cause
um do you not like doing dishes is it
the cooking element that you find quite
frustrating I've never been an amazing
cook I think that probably is my
downfall
um I mean it's okay that's okay we all
have different skills and talents I
think I I'm not and again I don't
necessarily subscribe to you need to
have a hot meal for dinner right
um which is probably why um do sometimes
stop by tesk on my way home we
especially it takes me about half an
hour on the trip to get back so why not
have dinner then and once I get home
I've got more time for anything else I
want to do very pragmatic
um I mean why is Wales targeting the
meal deal I I know that the claim is
that they're not particularly healthy
but they're a lot healthier than other
things you can buy in the supermarket
especially as you say if there's so much
choice now you know if you it's not just
crisps it's not just chocolate
um I mean why are they targeting the
meal deal and and what slippery slope is
this what it you know if you ban the
meal deal ban all sandwiches where does
this end well exactly I think that
they're obviously with the way the meal
deal works you can get things in
different combinations
obviously there's going to be a
combination that is the most unhealthy
and I think that's what people are
really focusing on there's combinations
of sandwiches crisps and drinks that can
reach up to over a thousand calories and
what you probably should try and avoid
for if you're having three meals a day
um but equally you can also have meal
deals that are exceptionally healthy and
that's what I like about you know it
makes sure you've got sandwiches that
offer check-in and and Seafoods and
that's you know your protein intake and
you have water in the side and fruit on
the side so for me I think that the the
horses mindset you know for Banning this
meal deal is a bit ludicrous given that
you can make it healthy and it's should
be up to individual choice I don't also
think that people are going to turn
around and become healthy overnight when
the meal deal disappears because right
if people are going to Tesco for
convenience then why not simply switch
to McDonald's or KFC or something or
just a bigger bag of crisps yeah exactly
yeah now I don't want to unnecessarily
upset you but I am going to ask a
difficult question if they were to ban
the meal deal and I appreciate you not
living in Wales but let's say
hypothetically speaking this work send
it to you what would you do without it
gosh it's something that I've not really
wanted to think about too much sure but
I do really rely on this as something to
get me through my my life basically it's
a big lifestyle change absolutely
um for me I think I probably would have
to take up cooking and I might just have
to revert to making my own sandwiches
or alternatively find some other fast
convenient way of having lunch and
budget do you think do you think it's a
sandwich then in particular I mean would
you get in that bread would you make the
sandwich is that do you think what you
would most Miss I think yeah for me I
think the sandwich is something that it
does definitely appeal with a mule deal
I've spoken to colleagues who are
absolutely shocked by this and I've
spoken to colleagues who don't like
sandwiches at all which I find also
completely shocking but yeah I think
that for me it's it's fast it's easy
it's quick and you can there's so many
different types of things you can put
into a sandwich so I yeah I would miss
it massively and I don't know what I
would do well Lucy I seriously hope that
you get some kind of endorsement out of
this segment because I think you're the
best representative they have thanks for
joining spectator TV thank you
and that's it for this week if you enjoy
spectator TV subscribe to our YouTube
channel just click the Subscribe button
at the bottom of this video and tap the
Bell icon to make sure you never miss
any of our videos thanks again for
watching and do join us again next week
[Music]
thank you